I should really research the origin of
the 10% of the brain a meme which is
wildly repeated in many places I don't
know exactly what the original statement
was referring to but probably it was
referring to the fact that the neurons
in the brain the neurons in the cortex
of the brain a fire sparsely in the
sense that they are not you know active
all the time sending electrical impulses
the the fire at much lower rates than
their you know that they would be
capable of hardware wise and but this
does not mean that they are not in use
all the time namely a neuron being
silent means something as opposed to not
meaning anything and therefore I I
really have no idea what it would mean
to say we are only using 10% of the of
the brain a as far as I'm aware
everybody uses most of the brain most of
the time you know I don't know exactly
how